Edward.
The first known as long shanks for is uncharacteristic height was a man among
men and the king among kings.
As a child,
he was so sick of you that few 40 would survive to even take the crown,
take it.
He devs immediately displaying a strength and determination that had been sorely
lacking.
He quickly established as authority with ruthless suppression of rebellion,
earning him the nickname of a hammer of the Scots and the adoration of all of
England.
In this week's biographics,
we get up close and personal with the man who was Edward Longshanks for King of
England.
Edward,
the first future King of England was born at Westminster Palace in London on
June the 17th 1239 he was the first born son of King Henry,
the third and Eleanor of Provence.
Henry was a great admirer of previous King Edward.
The confessor runs named his son in his honor.
That one,
it was not a well trials.
In fact,
he was so weak that the general consensus was that he wouldn't survive into
adulthood but survive.
He did growing into an unusually tool lens,
rather robust teenager.
He would eventually grow to a height of six foot two which allowed him to tower
over most of his contemporaries.
It was his unusual height which would lead soldiers to refer to him as
Longshanks.
During his formative years,
Edward was groomed to take the mantle of king.
He was educated by the best scholars and members of the clergy.
He overcame his physical weaknesses to become an Abl wielder of the sword and
club as well as a keen students of the arts and languages at the age of 15
Edward Ends it into an arranged marriage with a 13 year old Elena daughter of
Ferdinand.
The third of Castiel that Mulian was precipitated by the fear of a Castilian
invasion of the province of Gascony as part of that marriage contract and would
receive land groundswell for 15,000 marks annually in taxation.
This lands covered much of Ireland and Wales.
However,
the entitlement that the teenage prince had was only in name as the lands were
still controlled by his father and the income generated went not to him,
but rather do the role lefthand and Simon de Montfort the sixth I'll have lasta.
Vl of Lester was married to the king sister Edward did benefit from the marriage
alliance on a more personal level.
Unlike the vast majority of such a range do unions,
he ends.
Elena genuinely cared for each other and that fondness grew into a love that
lasts their entire lives.
King Henry was an extremely pious man whose main focus as king was on building
up the authority and symbolism of the church.
He devoted himself to rebuilding Westminster Rabih,
putting his energies into this project at the expense of more pressing concerns
of state.
A series of ill advised military forays,
each of which ended in failure,
added fuel to the fire of discontent with his reign.
Among the nobility,
attempts were made to usurp the king's authority and wrestle power away from
him.
The two most powerful Nobel factions at that time with a silly and Cologne
families who were opposed to each other.
Henry pushed a policy of neutrality between the camps in 1255 however,
the 16 year old Edward began signing with the solar family.
This marketers first active independence from his father.
In the following year,
Edward began associating with what was called the Lucy norm faction made up of
the half brother was of his father who were a French origin.
This group was largely despised by the nobility and had a reputation for being
rather uncouth and violence.
Concerns were expressed in the royal court over the increasing wildness of
Edwards conduct when he was with the Lucy minions.
Three years later,
a body of nobles drew up a documents known as the provisions of Oxford,
which spelled out a series of reforms designed to give the barons much more say
in the running of the king's governments.
The barons were especially opposed to the influence of the loosen yours
relations between Henry and his brother in law,
Simon demand fought HUD then strains from the very start.
Simon had not sought the king's permission for marriage,
do his sister Simon then proceeded to amass large debts naming the king as a
guarantor that again,
without his permission as long than it was at the forefront of the barons
efforts.
Do you bring reformance?
The pressure imposed eventually led to the king signing the provisions.
He was now obligated to seek the counsel of his barons on matters relating to
the governing of the kingdom as the pressure at the ends of mountain.
His father,
Edward remains loyal to his friends,
the loose in your arms and took a stance in opposition to the provisions of
Oxford.
But as the reform movement grew in intensity,
his position,
it's shifted.
On October,
1259 he announced that he was supportive of the goals of the barons and aligns
himself with his father's rival.
Simon demand fought in November at 1259 king Henry embarked on a voyage to
France and his absence,
Edwards opposition to his father.
The group.
He appointed several of the rebellious barons to important positions within the
royal court.
When news of this reaches farther in Normandy,
he was convinced that Edward was about to stage Nova throat.
He quickly returned to London,
do reimpose his position.
At first the outraged Henry refused to even see Edward,
but finally the sort of piece was broken between them by the Archbishop of
Canterbury.
It was decided that Edward was to go abroad,
which he did at the age of 21 in November,
1260 he ended up in France where he fell in love with his old pals.
Then Newson yawns.
Meanwhile,
in 1261 king Henry with the backing of the pope in Rome over through the
provisions of Oxford this at the Barron's do set up their own independent
parliaments with civil war looming.
This Nobel parliament,
it was dissolved and the noble rebellious barons.
They flat demoed fort himself,
all left the country,
but he returned two years later when the heat had died down to fit,
managed to raise a sizable army and marched on London the king vacillation and
seemed ready to give up his throne.
It was at this point that Edward stepped up and began to take control of the
situation.
Any hesitancy he had shown in supporting his father's rule had vanished and he
was now storage need determined to restore the king's dominance.
He took control of the king's army and that in defense if the realm,
the rentals were ousted from Windsor Castle,
a compromise of sorts was reached thanks to the intervention of King Louie.
The ninth of France even negotiated the agreement known as the me's of Mer.
The vase between the king and the barons was short lived in 1264 hostilities
broke out one small with the onset of what history recalls as the second Baron's
walk.
Once again,
the barons were led by Simon demand fought while the forces loyal to the king
were bubs with the control of the now 24 year old Prince Edward in the wake of a
series of smaller victories,
Edwards on the mess up with the forces of demand for that.
At the battle of Loos on May the 14th 1264 things went well for the royalist
forces as they managed to force the London contingents of the opposition into
retreat.
But then Edward made the mistake of breaking off with a portion of his army to
chase down the London is when he returns.
The main scene of the mantle is forces had been defeated.
Edward was taken as a prisoner and held until the following may when he managed
to escape.
Over the next few months,
the royalist forces steadily wore down the resistance army.
The most telling victory was that the battle of [inaudible] on August the fourth
1265 the Barron's army,
it was ravaged with many of its need is being put to the sword.
Simon de Montfort was himself kills when alliance was run through his body.
Edward then allowed US soldiers do mutilate the body,
including cutting off the testicles and hanging them over.
Demonic Montfort's knows such actions were strictly against the protocol of war,
which stipulated that nobles were to be treated humanely.
However they'd would consider demonic fit to be a traitor and therefore beyond
the rules of conduct.
The last of the rebels made a standard Kenilworth Castle.
Finally surrendering in accordance with the terms of the dictum of Kenilworth,
Edwards decisive actions and leadership skills during the barons rebellion,
Sjogren's and be a man of action.
Who possessed the courage,
ability,
and personality to be a great king?
Yes.
With the rebellion crushed and his father's rulership a should he put his focus
on an upcoming crusade.
King Louie,
the ninth of France was planning a crusade to North Africa in order to defeat
the Muslims and 1268 Edward lefting islands with a force of around 1,200 men
along with him was his wife Elena.
After crossing the channel and then the Mediterranean,
they arrived at North Sirica and you need to discover the French king was dead.
The result of a fatal bout of dysentery,
Edward was now the leader of the allied force and deep chose to withdraw the
fleet to Sicily.
However,
on routes a severe storm decimated the fleas and the French contingent decided
to return home rather than following the French example,
then would decided to forge ahead.
He landed at Acra on May the ninth of 1271 the and Anbar in the hardy land was
under serious threat from the Muslim states with jewelry and them already having
fallen in 1244 the Egyptian Mamluks well now threatening to take acro,
which I've just the Christian capital with a relatively small false of Matt.
There was this little Edward could do to stem the tide Muslim aggression.
The Mandolin Warrior King by bars had tens of thousands of men under his command
before departing for home.
However,
that would play a part in the negotiation of a truce with babe ours.
Once the treaty was signed,
he stayed for a period of time to ensure that its conditions would be carried
out.
One night in September of 1272 and assassin into the bed chamber of Edward and
Elinor in order to attempt to thrust a poisonous dagger into the prince is on
and was able to fend off the attack and kill the assassin.
Legend has it that I dunno,
sucks the poison from our husband Zam thus saving his life
in the wake of the foils.
Assassination plot,
the role coupled,
they left the holy lands.
Upon saving to Sicily,
Edward was given the news that his father,
the king had died.
Edward had been weakened to bind the poison attack and so now as King of
England's,
he and Elena is queen took allegedly trip home the situation back in England.
It was pretty stable,
so he didn't really see a need to rush back.
Edward made his way home through bitterly ans then onto France crossing the
channel.
In early August of 1274 Edward was officially crowned King Edward.
The first on August the 19th 1274 at Westminster Abbey when the crown was placed
upon his head,
a chronic alert reported that Edward immediately took it off again and stated
that he would only wear it again when all of the territory that was lost during
the kingship of his father was returned.
The new king,
which 35 years old,
he was tall,
muscular,
and his militarily adept.
He was the man of action that his father had simply not.
Then.
You see,
he enjoyed the roughest and most dangerous forms of hunting such as going after
bores and wolves.
As a younger man,
he was prone to flying off the handle,
but age had restrained as temper.
By the time he ascended to the throne,
he had built a reputation as a loyal friends and they devoted ruler.
However,
he was also known as a hard man who could be harsh,
even cruel,
and the furtherance of his own will Edwards rain.
It was not going to be a continuation of his father's weekend Leoneans rule.
He immediately set about reestablishing the dominance of the crown.
His other power was unquestioned,
but he sold it.
In order to retain power,
he had to institute policies that were popular with the people.
Does that mean you prevent a repeat of the civil war that had scarred his
father's reign?
He made lasting provision for the lower classes to be represented in
parliaments.
This established the basis of the House of Commons,
which today is the predominant house in the English political system.
During the first years of his reign would focus primarily on streamlining and is
reforming the administration of its governments.
He then turned his attention to the situation that was a caring and Wales,
the Prince of Wales Lewin and APP Griff am had been handed the title buying King
Henry the third in return for agreeing to pay homage to the English Crown
Lewellen.
However,
it had been an ally of Henry and Edwards Enemies,
Simon Demand Fort and set about conquering of the Welsh Kingdoms and was now
threatening to move against England itself.
That would acted preemptively needing a force of 10,000 across the Welsh border.
However,
the unpopularity at home prevented him raising a sizable on each counter.
The English invasion.
In fact,
as Izombie Zombie moved up,
the Welsh countryside,
Edwards forces were strengthened by the addition of local Welsh armies who were
opposed to a woman.
Among those who joined Edward was Lewellen's own brother to feed.
The upstart was soon deposed and Edward claims,
large swaths of Welsh territory is his own.
He rewarded a fed by giving him a small parcel of land that was not pleasing to
him and he felt that he deserved much more for his service to the crown.
In 1282 to it led a revolt against the king that was soon joined by his ceiling.
Brother Llewellyn and angry Edward responded by invading wells the second time.
This time,
however,
he was determined to go all out with eight three pronged attack from the south
east and the north.
The English invasion was unstoppable,
resulting in the stomping out of the rebellion and the death in battle of
Llewellyn for his parts.
His affairs was captured and executed.
Edward consolidated as a Victorian wells by constructing a series of castle's
throughout the lands.
The most impressive was that canal oven.
It was here that Edward's son and future and with the second was born in 1284
the now vacant size love Prince of Wales was bestowed upon the child since.
Since that time,
the dash to the British throne has been given that title in a ceremony that is
held it can have on console when it came to foreign relations.
Edward did his best to maintain peaceful relations with this European
counterparts despite the fact that Phillip,
the third of France was his cousin.
Relations between the two powers were under constant tension.
When Philip died in 1285 Edward Cross the channel in order to pay homage to the
new French King Phillip the fourth.
He did not return to England until 1289 spending much time in the dump.
She of Gasconade,
which was one of his possessions and 1287 it would took the cross for the second
time intending it to stage another far more successful crusade to retake the
holy lands from the Muslims.
He knew that success in this enterprise depended on the stitching together of a
truly international European alliance.
Towards that end.
He expended much ethics trying to present a piece among the powers,
Edwards long absence from buns and had thrown the government into confusion and
chaos.
He returned to discover the corruption was rife and was forced in discussed to
expel many of his judges and ministers.
On November the 28th 1290 Eleanor died after suffering a protracted illness that
may have been malaria.
She was just 48 years of age,
having spent 35 of them at Edwards side.
The king was distraught at the loss of his wife.
He became a hardened man in the wake of her loss,
more bitter and rooting in nature.
Edwards campaign against the well should impose huge financial burdens upon this
nation.
Taxes with a main way to meet those expenses into prime source of that taxation
where the Jews of England's Edward Tax the Jews far more heavily than any other
group.
In 1279 he ordered the arrest of all the heads of Jewish households throughout
the country.
About 300 of them were put to death the following year.
All Jews were ordered to attend special sermons,
preached by Dominican fries.
In order to convert them to Christianity.
Then in 1290 Edward issued the edict of expulsion by which old Jews were kicked
out of England.
It wasn't until 16 six that the Jewish band in England was finally lifted
from 1290 onward.
Edwards attention was focused on troubles in Scotland following the death of
Alexander the third and 1286 Scotland's whether it's governed in the name of his
granddaughter,
Margaret King Edward had made the suggestion that his eldest surviving son
Edward of kind of on Margaret should be United in marriage,
bringing about the union of England and Scotland.
Before this could happen though Margaret died,
the Scottish throne was now in dispute with a number of claimants and the
English king was asked to play the role of arbitrator and Edwin agreed,
but on the condition that the claimant's accept him as their overlord.
In 1292 he awarded the throne to John Balliol who was crowned as the new king.
It didn't take long,
however,
the Scottish people to resent the jurisdiction or control this Edward held over
their country.
John was deprived of all this power and the Scots formed an alliance with
France.
By this time,
England's relations with the French had deteriorated.
Things that come to a head when Phillip the fourth refuse to restore the Duchy
of Gascony to Edgewood.
In 1293 Edward declared war on France at the very time that the Scots had United
with Scotland to make a bad situation worse,
the Welsh choose this time to rise in rebellion.
King John had Scotland gathered his forces in March of 1296 Edward Mustard,
his forces and again marched into battle many Scottish Nobels,
including Robert,
the Bruce sided with Edward,
who's first target city was the city of Bowick.
It turns into a brutal massacre of the Scots with many people being killed.
The next target was the costly Dunbar.
Despite having the higher grounds,
the Scottish defenders were routed on April the 27th at 1296 the Scottish army
was virtually wiped out,
allowing Edward to quickly take a succession of castles.
All the remains was for King John to surrender.
On July the second John Center pleading letter to Edward Begging forgiveness and
Massey.
Edward accepted,
but only off to subjugating John to a series of humiliations including having
the Scottish coat of arms torn from his socket.
He was then thrown into the tower of London,
but that God wasn't finished with Scotland's.
He was determined to stamp out any vestiges of Scottish independence and to
absorb it's people into the English kingdom.
He demanded Osa fealty from all Scottish nobles and magnets and either refuse to
do so.
We're hunted down as outlaws
after conquering the Scots,
Edward returned south.
He now has a focus on issues with the French.
However,
the masters in Scotland,
we're not ready to subject themselves to the heel of Edward Longshanks
resistance.
Grew under three divergent leaders in the southwest,
Robert the Bruce and merged as the head of a gathering of nobles and church
leaders in the northeast.
The struggle was spearheaded by Andrew Murray and in the center of the country
forces were being gathered by an obscure,
a member of a noble family named William Wallace.
In 1297 Wallace mad the English Sheriff of Line Arc William to hassle rig this
act,
United,
the disjointed pockets of resistance into a full blown rebellion.
Two months later with a situation reaching a point,
Edward was forced to send his left tenants in to deal with the situation.
Meanwhile,
he had his own battle to fight in Flanders in France,
even though he didn't want his conquest of Scotland to run Ravelry.
You also knew that abandoning planned French invasion would only strengthen the
rebels hand as things stand down.
The British underestimated the strength of the Scottish resistance.
What appeared to be a Scottish attempt is and negotiated surrender was in fact
a,
was to allow Wallace more time together as army with his army strengthens.
Wallace managed to push the English from five path share and done deep.
The climactic battle occurred at Stirling bridge.
The English out numbered the sculpts six to one,
but when the leader of the first vanguard here to crossing him was reputedly
struck down by Wallace himself thousands following turn flat.
While this went on to exploit the terrain and generally outmaneuver the British
to win a resounding victory.
Wallace quickly that is ever growing forces to overthrow the remaining English
outposts in Scotland.
He then crossed the border and invaded English territory.
After taking Northumberland,
he reached as far south as cocky mouth.
With this,
it was time for Edward to take control of the situation.
Personally.
In 1298 king's Zombie gathered out Roxborough with the king joining them.
In early July,
he marched north with 17,000 men.
By now,
Wallace had returned to sculpins.
Edward was determined to hunt him down though while it's high then it was not
keen to engage the king and drew the Monica feather north.
This Scott said,
strip the lands and leaving the English with no food and just stretch it out.
Supply line with his army disintegrating.
Edward had a stroke of luck when intelligence was received that Wallison his men
wept stationed at fall.
Kirk about 20 miles away,
beginning immediately such as Ami and the direction of foul cock.
The Scots,
they were surprised that they were in a strongly entrenched position.
In the end,
the the strength of the English infantry and cavalry assaults was too much for
the Scottish army and they were torn to pieces while it's managed to escape and
led pockets of resistance for the next seven years,
but the English,
they were able to reestablish dominance over Scotland's.
In 30 no five William Wallace was finally captured by the English.
They was taken to London where he was hung,
drawn and quartered.
However,
this wasn't the end of the Scottish problem for Edwin.
In 1306 Robert the Bruce assassinated rival for the throne,
which had been vacant for 10 years.
He then had himself crowned King of Scotland.
He was quickly defeated in battle with the English after which he went into
hiding or need to return in 30 no seven to conduct,
hit and run raids on English,
fortresses,
Edwards,
and now in failing health was still the time and to bring up this latest
Scottish rental to heal,
he again gathered is Ami and headed north on the journey.
Does Scotland.
However,
the king contracted dysentery on the morning of July the seventh 1307 he died
just a few miles short of the Scottish border.
It is said that he left instructions with his son for the flesh to be boiled
from his body and his bones to be preserved.
Then every time the Scots should rebel against him,
his son would carry with him the bones of his father instead of his body was
taken back to lungs and where it was placed in a plane.
Tomb in Westminster Abbey,
700 years later,
that to Ms Dolan display reminding visitors of the strength and authority of one
of England's most impressive Monnox does.
I really hope you found the video interesting.
If you did,
please do.
Gives a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos every day of the week.
Also,
I've got another channel it's called today.
I found out we do actually daily videos on that channel,
exploring all manner of interesting things.
Please find a link to that on the screen now as well as below this video and as
always,
thank you for watching.